[Music]
there have been 24 official James Bond
movies with six actors portraying the
iconic British agent after 56 years it's
one of the longest-running franchises in
film history across that half-century
which entries are the best in this
legendary series these are the top five
best movies about bond James Bond number
five From Russia With Love you never
forget your first and Sean Connery
polished a pearl James Bond is on a
mission to receive a device and
intelligence from a defecting Russian
spy Tatiana Romanova the plot thickens
when it's revealed that she's a double
agent but may have also developed real
feelings for bond from Russia With Love
is the second in the Bond series and
with twice the budget of its predecessor
dr. know it was able to accomplish much
more right away it features one of my
favorite opening credit visuals the real
women's bodies with projections stay in
the test of time over the animated
silhouettes that were to come unlike a
lot of other films in the series this
felt like they really use their bond
ladies well
Moneypenny is the best but from combat
to consent the other femme fatales are
presented so well in such an early film
there are some great lines throughout
the series but my favorite are these
clips that showcase bonds creativity and
cool under pressure we'll have a much
safer journey not mad about his tale are
you bond even buys Romanova outfits for
a bit of a fashion show I mean how is I
not going to love this followed by the
classic fight sequence in the train car
using the layout of its close quarters
in intimate camera angles to make the
sequence feel extremely personal and
urgent this movie had the unforgettable
gadgets like this Swiss Army briefcase
and knife shoe and also the best code
phrase that makes you feel like you're
in on the spy lingo every time it's
uttered excuse me
can I vote ahem bats I use a life of it
distilled until they go wrong this movie
has everything you've come to expect
from James Bond wiretaps double paned
glass assassins in disguise a boat chase
a helicopter cheese seduction and of
course some classic Bond wisdom red wine
with fish well that should have told me
something number four Goldfinger in 1964
James Bond got his first blockbuster
movie in Goldfinger now it has become
arguably the most iconic Bond film
go ahead list a quote or character
chances are it's in this movie my name
is Pussy Galore
there are so many factors working
together to make this movie truly
memorable and thrilling the writing is
great introducing tongue-in-cheek humor
to the character that Connery plays off
perfectly
shocking positively shocking the villain
Goldfinger was perfect he was cunning
controlling and over-the-top in a
wonderful way he is my favorite Bond
villain you expect me to talk Mr Bond I
expect you to die the way he had Bond
girl Jill Masterson killed by being
painted goals was unique and created an
iconic image that was featured in Life
Magazine there was even a rumor going
around for decades that the actress that
played her was actually killed by skin a
fixation on set the music was awesome
this was the first Bond movie to feature
the title song being played over the
opening sequence the theme song was
touchy and kind of sexy the way that it
was incorporated throughout the score
was genius Goldfinger became the new
template by which many future Bond
movies were created it was the first
movie where bond relied on gadgets in
addition to his great spy skills and
introduced audiences to the cue
briefings and incidentally we'd
appreciate its return along with all
your other equipment
in tact for once when you returned from
the field oh you'd be surprised amount
of wear and tear that goes on out there
in the field but perhaps one of the most
iconic moments to come out of Goldfinger
is how Mr Bond prefers his martinis a
martini shaken not stirred Cheers
number three Goldeneye
Goldeneye is a very important film in
the Bond franchise and no not just
because of the video game in 1986
double-oh-seven was on a mission in
Russia with his close friend double O
six aka Alec Trevelyan when Alec has
apparently killed bond completes the
mission but carries his friend's death
with him into the future nine years
later Alec resurfaces as the leader
behind a plan to wipe out London's
entire financial history and destroy its
economy while electronically robbing the
Bank of England he attempts to achieve
this with a series of satellites called
Goldeneye bond now has to stop his
former friend before England's entire
history is eradicated Pierce Brosnan and
director Martin compel successfully
brought bond into the 90s with this epic
revamp of the character since the
previous Bond films released the Cold
War had ended and the Soviet Union had
crumbled they took this opportunity to
address the character somewhat stale
tropes but they did in a very smart and
engaging way the cast in this movie is
incredible
Brosnan proved to fit this role like a
glove and is still one of the best bonds
to ever tie the bow tie specifically in
Goldeneye there's just a depth to him
that we hadn't seen much of before Sean
Bean is double O six was a great idea
for a villain and bonds friendship with
him set the tone for an engaging
through-line
that had us caring about the characters
past Alec Trevelyan is one of bonds best
adversaries and Sean Bean was the
perfect choice to bring him to life on
screen the introduction of Judi Dench's
M in this movie is perhaps the most
important she lasted longer than Brosnan
in the series and was a mainstay for
many years her assessment of bond in
their first meeting was nothing short of
a powerful statement that showed just
how different this version of the
character was going to be you don't like
me bummed you can't guide my methods you
think I'm an accountant a bean-counter
more interested in my numbers in your
instinct we thought had occurred to me
good because I think you're a sexist
misogynist dinosaur
a relic of the Cold War overall the
movie is filled with fun action deeper
characters and an interesting plot that
revitalized the series for a new era
number 2 Skyfall 2012 was the 50th
anniversary of the Bond franchise so
expectations were high on the movie that
would celebrate it
Skyfall delivered and surpassed on these
expectations
Skyfall deals with the recurring theme
of mi6 and James Bond being relics of
the past things that are no longer
necessary or even sometimes welcomed in
today's world what this movie does
wonderfully is combined the new grittier
more realistic bond with the sometimes
corny bond to the past there are
callbacks to the older movies and past
adventures that are done in a way that
does not take away from the flow of the
movie come
[Music]
don't exactly Christmas is it you were
expecting an exploding pen we don't
really go in for that anymore one of the
best things about the movie though is
that it doesn't just focus on James Bond
it really develops the character of M
and most importantly her relationship
with bond and her other agents Dench
does a wonderful job in her last
performance as the character her
chemistry with Craig is undeniable and
builds a strong central focus for the
movie I think you lost your nerve what
do you expect a bloody apology you know
the rules of the game you've been
playing it long enough
we both have maybe too long speak for
yourself
Skyfall also has an extremely strong
villain Javier Bardem gives a
captivating performance as Silva a
betrayed agent from m's days in Hong
Kong mi6
you're living in their ruling as well
you just don't know it yet at least here
there are no old ladies giving orders
and no little gadgets plus the score and
cinematography for Skyfall are fantastic
everything came together to form a great
cinematic experience for fans and
newcomers to the franchise
[Music]
and the number one best James Bond movie
is Casino Royale
Casino Royale is not just the best Bond
movie it's quite possibly one of my
favorite movies period in this daring
reboot James Bond starts from scratch we
see him earn his double-o status and
sent on his first major mission to stop
a man nameless sheep from winning money
at a high-stakes poker game to fund
terrorist organizations
however the rabbit hole goes much deeper
than Bond or mi6 could have predicted
accompanied by the stunning Vesper Lynd
James Bond fights for more than just a
card game in this stylistic cool brutal
character driven and emotional adventure
I am very passionate on how much I love
this movie I could talk about it for
hours but this thing is nearly flawless
Martin Campell returned to direct 11
years after golden eye with a new Bond
in Daniel Craig and I know it's
controversial to say but his portrayal
has been the most dynamic and relatable
of any of his predecessors he's without
a doubt in my mind been in the two best
Bond films to date with one more coming
out next year the style of this movie
speaks for itself
the black and white intro through the
masterful opening credits sequence is a
feast for the eyes while the late Chris
Cornell's you know my name fills your
ears with pure excitement which results
in the most exhilarating first few
minutes of any film I've ever seen I get
absolutely amped every single time I see
it the music throughout the whole film
adds so much and the visuals may not be
as epic as Skyfall but they're
exceptional in their own right thrilling
and innovative action sequences combined
with quiet poignant character scenes and
intense suspenseful moments add up to a
perfectly paced movie Vesper Lynd m and
the Sheep surround Daniel Craig's
double-oh-seven
in a tragic story that is as
heartbreaking as it is heart-pounding I
love Casino Royale it is the best Bond
movie right now and it perfectly
represents the appeal of this character
molded him to fit the time it came out
in and added more character and grit to
this icon than had ever been seen before
it may have felt new and different but
at the end of the day you know his name
phoned
James Bond there are a lot of Bond
movies that just barely missed this list
so you can check out how the honorable
mentions stacked up in a new episode of
the countdown continue on my personal
channel right now we want to hear what
you guys think what's your favorite Bond
movie what do you want to see us cover
next on the show leave a comment and let
us know to keep in touch you could like
my Facebook page or follow along on
Twitter then you can find me on Twitter
Instagram or Twitter I stream on
Tuesdays and Thursdays and you can find
me on Facebook Instagram or Twitter
we'll catch you right back here next
week with the worst of mister bond on a
brand-new episode of 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you